>>> THIS IS "DON LEMON TONIGHT."
LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
DO YOU FEEL A LITTLE CALMER
TODAY?
DO YOU FEEL LIKE THERE WERE
FEWER ANGRY VOICES OUT THERE?
WELL, MAYBE THAT'S BECAUSE
FACEBOOK ALONG WITH INSTAGRAM
AND WHAT'S APP WERE DOWN FOR
MOST OF THE DAY AND YOU KNOW
WHAT THAT DID.
THAT SILENCED THE FEEDBACK LOOP
THAT SEEMS TO BE MAKING
AMERICANS ANGRIER AND ANGRIER.
PEOPLE COULDN'T YELL AT EACH
OTHER ONLINE SO PEOPLE WERE
MAYBE LOOKING FOR OTHER PLACES
TO DO IT.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO THIS.
THIS IS FACEBOOK WHISTLE BLOWER
FRANCIS THAT'S CLAIMING THAT
ANGER IS GOOD FOR FACEBOOK'S
BUSINESS AND ALLEGES A SCALE OF
THE PROBLEM IS MUCH WORSE THAN
THE COMPANY IS LETTING ON OR
THAT THE PUBLIC EVEN
UNDERSTANDS.
SHE'S ON "60 MINUTES" AND HERE
IS WHAT SHE SAID.
>> IT'S OWN RESEARCH IS SHOWING
THAT CONTENT THAT IS HATEFUL,
THAT IS DIVISIVE, THAT
POLARIZING, IT'S EASIER TO
INSPIRE PEOPLE TO ANGER THAN IT
IS TO OTHER EMOTIONS.
FACEBOOK HAS REALIZED THAT IF
THEY CHANGE THE ALGORITHM TO BE
SAFER, PEOPLE WILL SPEND LESS
TIME ON THE SITE AND CLICK ON
LESS ADS AND MAKE LESS MONEY.
>> OKAY.
SO I MEAN, LOOK, THAT'S WHAT
SHE'S SAYING.
BUT THINK ABOUT WHAT SHE'S
SAYING, THOUGH, RIGHT?
SHE'S A FORMER FACEBOOK EMPLOYEE
AND SHE'S ALLEGING THE COMPANY
IS WILLING TO LET ANGRY RHETORIC
SPREAD AS LONG AS IT'S GOOD FOR
THEIR BOTTOM LINE.
NOW THAT WHISTLE BLOWER IS GOING
TO APPEAR BEFORE A SENATE
COMMITTEE.
IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN TOMORROW.
CNN OBTAINED PREPARED TESTIMONY
SAYING SHE KNOWS FACEBOOK COULD,
HER WORD, DESTROY HER.
AND COMPARING ALL OF THIS TO BIG
TOBACCO ALLEGING THEY KNOW IT'S
TOXIC, BUT THEY DO IT ANYWAY.
A QUOTE HERE.
WHEN WE REALIZE TOBACCO
COMPANIES WERE HIDING THE HARMS
IT CAUSED, THE GOVERNMENT TOOK
ACTION.
WHEN WE FIGURED OUT CARS WERE
SAFER WITH SEAT BELTS, THE
GOVERNMENT TOOK ACTION AND TODAY
THE GOVERNMENT IS TAKING ACTION
AGAINST COMPANIES THAT HID
EVIDENCE OF OPEN I DIOIDS.
I IMPLORE YOU TO DO THE SAME
HERE.
FACEBOOK IS RESPONDING AND
ANOTHER QUOTE, EVERY DAY OUR
TEAMS HAVE TO BALANCE PROTECTING
THE ABILITY OF BILLIONS OF
PEOPLE TO EXPRESS THEMSELVES
OPENLY WITH THE NEED TO KEEP THE
PLATFORM A SAFE AND POSITIVE
PLACE.
WE CONTINUE TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS TO TACKLE THE
SPREAD OF MISINFORMATION AND
HARMFUL CONTENT TO SUGGEST WE
ENCOURAGE BAD CONTENT AND DO
NOTHING IS JUST NOT TRUE.
END QUOTE FROM FACEBOOK.
OKAY?
SO LOOK, NOBODY IS SUGGESTING
THAT EVERYTHING YOU SEE ON
FACEBOOK IS HARMFUL.
NO ONE IS SUGGESTING THAT.
BUT IT'S ALSO NO SECRET THAT THE
PLATFORM HAS BEEN USED TO SPREAD
HATE AND MISINFORMATION, HATE
AND MISINFORMATION THAT JUST
SERVE TO PIT US AGAINST EACH
OTHER.
LOOK, YOU SEE IT EVERYWHERE.
THE ANGER IS EVERYWHERE AND IT'S
TOXIC.
ANGER ON PLANES.
ANGER OVER VACCINES.
ANGER OVER MASKS.
IT SEEMS LIKE AMERICA IS ANGRIER
THAN EVER.
TWO PROTESTERS FLIPPING OVER A
TESTING TAB LE AT A TENT AT A
MOBILE COVID TESTING CENTER
TODAY.
CAMERAS EVERYWHERE.
IT'S ALL CAUGHT ON TAPE.
WHAT WOULD HAVE THOUGHT SCHOOL
BOARD MEETINGS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WOULD ERUPT OVER MASK
MANDATES?
SCHOOL BOARDS?
WHO THOUGHT PARENTS WOULD BE
FURIOUS OVER ATTEMPTS TO PROTECT
THEIR CHILDREN FROM A DEADLY
PANDEMIC.
>> CALM DOWN.
CALM DOWN.
WE KNOW -- WE KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
WE KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
>> WE WILL FIND YOU.
>> YOU WILL NEVER BE ALLOWED IN
PUBLIC AGAIN.
>> I'M GOING TO COMFORT
EVERYBODY THAT COMES AT MY KID
WITH THIS STUPID RIDICULOUS
MANDATE.
>> WE ARE THE STORM AND WE ARE
READY AND WHEN THIS WHOLE THING
CRUMBLES TO THE GROUND, WE WILL
BE HERE TO HOLD YOU ACCOUNTABLE
FOR YOUR CRIMES AGAINST
HUMA
HUMANITY.
>> NO MORE MASKS!
>> RIGHT HERE, LOOK, RIGHT HERE.
SO AS YOU CAN SEE, FISTS ARE NOW
FLYING.
ALL OF THIS ON LIVE TELEVISION.
FISTS ARE FLYING.
>> YOU ARE ALLOWING CHILD ABUSE.
YOU ARE ALLOWING CHILD ABUSE.
YOU WITH YOUR SNOTTY LITTLE
FACE, YOU'RE ALLOWING IT, AS
WELL.
>> YOU TREAT THE PARENTS OF
THESE CHILDREN AS DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS USING OUR MEN IN BLUE
AGAINST US.
YOUR POWER HUNGRY DICTATORSHIP
HAS GOTTEN OUT OF CONTROL.
THIS IS NO LONGER ABOUT OUR
SAFETY.
IT IS ABOUT CONTROL.
>> NO ONE KNOWS HISTORY OR
REMEMBERS HISTORY.
I AM CALLING ON CHURCHES, ACTIVE
DUTY MILITARY, VETERAN S
S.
WE KNOW IN THIS ROOM.
WE KNOW THAT.
THANKS FOR SHOWING YOUR COLORS.
>> AND WHEN THERE IS TIME TO
QUOTE THE FAMOUS POLITICIAN
ADOLPH HITLER, WHEN DIPLOMACY
ENDS, WAR BEGINS.
>> I HAVE SAID IT BEFORE.
THESE MASK WARS OVER WHAT PEOPLE
LIKE TO CALL THEIR FREEDOM, WHAT
KIND OF FREEDOM IS THAT.
>> WE ARE FOR FREEDOM ALL THE
WAY.
>> WHAT KIND OF FREEDOM IS THAT?
FREEDOM FOR KIDS TO GET SICK?
THE FREEDOM FOR THEM TO BE
QUARANTINED.
THAT'S NOT FREEDOM.
THERE IS THE ANGER OVER CRITICAL
RACE THEORY STOKED BY LIES USING
IT AS A POLITICAL WEAPON.
TERRIFYING PARENTS WITH THE
PROVABLY FALSE LIE THAT CRITICAL
RACE THEORY, WHICH ISN'T EVEN
TAUGHT TO CHILDREN IS ABOUT
HATING WHITE PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT.
THE MORALITY AND VALUES ARE
SLIPPING FROM OUR FINGERS BUT WE
WILL NOT LET THIS HAPPEN.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN CHRIST AND THE
CONSTITUTION AND BELIEVE IN
AMERICA, DO NOT LET THIS COUNTRY
FALL.
>> CRITICAL RACE THEORY IN FACT
PITS BLACK PEOPLE AGAINST WHITE
PEOPLE AND HAS AN END GAME GOAL
OF RESTRUCTURING AMERICA TO AN
AUTHORITARIAN REGIME.
>> YOU'RE TEACHING CHILDREN TO
HATE OTHERS BECAUSE OF THEIR
SKIN COLOR, AND YOU'RE FORCING
THEM TO LIE ABOUT OTHER KIDS
GENDER.
I AM DISGUSTED BY YOUR BIGOTRY
AND YOUR DEPRAVITY.
>> SHAME ON YOU!
SHAME ON YOU!
>> I'VE SAID THIS A MILLION
TIMES.
CRITICAL RACE THEORY IS NOT
BEING TAUGHT IN GRADE SCHOOLS.
NOT ABOUT HATING WHITE PEOPLE
BUT STUDYING THE FACT, THAT'S
RIGHT, THE FACT THAT SYSTEMIC
RACISM IS PART OF SOCIETY AND
INSTEAD, PEDDLERS OF LIES ARE
USING IT TO STOKE ANGER.
DON'T KID YOURSELF.
THE SIMMERING RAGE IS
EVERYWHERE, EVERYWHERE.
LOOK, THE ENTIRE TWO HOURS I'M
ON THE AIR TONIGHT, I COULD GIVE
YOU EXAMPLE AFTER EXAMPLE AFTER
EXAMPLE BUT HERE IS ONE.
DR. FAUCI HAS GOTTEN DEATH
THREATS FOR TRYING TO SAVE
AMERICANS FROM A KILLER VIRUS
AND ANTI-SEMITISM AND ANTI ASIAN
HATE FLOURISHING.
>> IN SURVEILLANCE VIDEO
RELEASED BY THE NYPD YOU SEE THE
VICIOUS ATTACK UP FOLD.
A WOMAN WHOM AUTHORITIES
IDENTIFIED AS A 65-YEAR-OLD
ASIAN-AMERICAN IS PUSHED TO THE
GROUND.
HER ATTACKER KICKING HER IN THE
HEAD AGAIN AND AGAIN.
POLICE SAY THE MAN ALLEGEDLY
YELLED EXPLETIVES AT HER SAYING
YOU DON'T BELONG HERE.
>> JESUS.
IT'S H